you
so I'm here with the man that needs no
introduction bang the dream come on me I
knew it you have kind of built yourself
as somebody it doesn't matter the cost
it doesn't matter the label if dream
likes it dreams wearing it yeah I don't
give a [ __ ] when you go shopping then
when you have like however the process
is like take me through it what are you
thinking well first we wake up and
probably keep on your Plaza slippers
that they give you okay walk like about
a plot down the street to Bergdorf and
Goodman okay you go upstairs to the
third floor okay and whatever you're
gonna wear today you haven't decided yet
you just look around till you see
something beautiful in its like that one
piece may be beautiful you may not know
where it comes from and it may be tacky
and [ __ ] with those jeans but i really
look good fun but what is like the major
style influenced this is like how I
write songs it's a salty-sweet theory
like okay the base is hidden hard on the
record there and try to write the
sweetest thing over the top of it and
that creates the best blend of the song
so what I try to do it if I wear a
leather jacket like this and a nice
shirt or whatever you try to [ __ ] it up
by putting teams on a Jordans on or
whatever it is have to create a balance
I think that's my what my style is so
we're going to mix things up we're gonna
put you in a shirt and tie but also keep
with the leather some really really
really incredible sneakers yeah things
the Louboutins yeah we put those yeah
so we still have the labels dolce
gabbana jacket band of outsiders tie
Tiffany's watch but taking Vanetta bell
christian louboutin sneakers showing the
sneakers so like the seats and my bins
this louboutin sneakers actually exudes
probably more of what's very hood of me
but very another you know in just a high
life type of feeling also so it's like
the contrast between both that I thought
that data that I thought that that
sounds like Michael don't oh you just
ours wrap
you